hello and welcome it's February 20th 7th
2023 we're here in active inference
bookstream number 2.1 with Thomas Parr
as well as Terry and Ali so thank you
all for joining this should be a very
fun discussion and let's go first by way
of introduction and beginning to Thomas
welcome and please
how did you come to write this textbook
in collaboration with pizulo and friston
well again thank you very much for
having me here
um
how did we come to write the textbooks
good question I think
um I think Giovanni was the the person
who really had the idea and pushed for
this that I think um Carl has already
previously been approached by
um by the editor who ended up managing
application of the book
um and
when Giovanni had the idea that this
would be a really useful contribution
um he and I had a number of discussions
about it both in in London and in Rome
where he's based
um and sort of put out a plan and and
sort of came up with something that we
hoped would be useful for the community
I suppose part of the part of the reason
why we thought it'd be a useful thing to
do is that active inference is a very
multi-disciplinary type field that draws
a lot from lots of different domains
and I think one of the one of the
struggles you know we all had when we
started out in it and I think certainly
what the students and uh people who are
interested in the topic say to us is
that it's often quite difficult to
trying to find all of these different
topics trying to find the right
background when they don't all come from
one field so putting it all together in
one book with a consistent notation
consistent language and trying to make
it complete we hoped would just make the
field a little bit more accessible
um to others who wanted to get involved
how did this dovetail or integrate with
your own Education and Research
directions like what phases or stages
were you moving through well this
discussion was happening
well I think so when we initially
started discussing it it must have been
probably the last year of my PhD and so
by that stage I'd spent uh three or four
sorry two to three years
um sort of getting to grips with active
inference
um having spent you know being
relatively recent in terms of learning
some of the key material myself I think
it was quite a good stage to be at in
terms of thinking about what I would
have wanted to know a few years
previously
um the actual writing of the book then
carried on over the next
year or two
um and so by that stage I was I was back
in clinical training as well
which I think is also a useful
perspective in terms of some of the
later chapters and thinking about
application of active infant site models
in the context of clinical conditions
and Psychiatry and neurology and those
sorts of areas
that's actually a really interesting
note how did the clinical experiences
give a perspective on the book or how
did the book or you're learning in these
abstract and theoretical domains give a
different Insight in the clinical
setting
it's a good question and I think you're
right to highlight the bi-directionality
of it that both the useful in in
different ways
um I think for me the clinical setting
is quite useful in terms of thinking you
know first of all in interacting the
different sort of different sort of um
audience so people who may be much more
skilled on the clinical side of things
maybe add less experience on the
mathematical computational side of
things but may still find the concepts
very useful so from that side of things
it's quite a useful exercise in being
able to communicate these things
um and then there's sort of the
interaction on the patient side of
things and trying to you know I think it
makes a big difference first of all in
interacting with patients has an impact
on how you might think about the
interesting questions and the things you
might want to use them to entrance for
but also having an understanding of
principles behind it helps you I think
formulate your questions about how
individual patients might present or the
reasons for that I think is a useful way
of of thinking about I mean I suppose on
two levels so one one in terms of
understanding
um
understanding particular sorts of
pathology in terms of the inferences
that might have gone wrong
um but also in terms of understanding
your own active influential processes
when you're trying to work out what's
going on yourself asking the right sort
of questions to gather the right sort of
information and and test those internal
hypotheses I think that's a very useful
way of thinking about
being a doctor
awesome yeah I like to say about that
the Bayesian optimal differential
diagnosis
Ali or Terry on any of these
thoughts do you have any questions or
comments you want to raise there or any
follow-ups
uh well yeah actually I just wanted to
ask uh what are the intended audience of
the book and what do you think are the
minimum prerequisites for going through
the whole book because I'm sure you'll
agree that even today the intersection
between the people who are well versed
in mathematics and the people who have a
solid background in say neurobiology are
quite narrow so
um
so what's the solution here and what um
did you think about
about the organizational structure of
the book that could accommodate various
uh audiences so
um yeah
again another really good question and I
think you're right to highlight that
that intersection is relatively narrow
and there are lots of lots of people who
I think
I struggle to feel involved in in those
kinds of discussions
um and you're absolutely right to say
that and I think you know what one of
the solutions is is the sorts of things
that you guys are doing in terms of
setting up these reading groups trying
to open that up trying to provide
educational resources I think that's
really very important
um in terms of the specific questions
about the book itself who's the audience
well
and you know what are the prerequisites
I think it sort of depends what you want
to get out of it and what your purpose
is in reading it
um so some aspects of the book I suppose
will appeal more to some audiences and
others to to other kinds of audience
um I would hope that the readership or
the audience is relatively broad because
we've tried to provide as much
background as we can on sort of the
mathematical and the neurobiological
side of things to try and
um
complement the skill set of whoever's
not in that intersection who comes to it
and who who may be need a bit more sort
of neurobiological grounding or who may
need a bit more mathematical and
Technical grounding
um but I think ultimately you like with
most textbooks you don't necessarily
need to come to it thinking I'm going to
understand everything in this book when
I come away from it some people may want
to
um but other people depending upon what
they want to get out of it they might
say actually what I really want to get
out of this is an understanding of
some of the the kind of message passing
as it's manifests in the brain whereas
other people might come to it and say
actually I already understand a bit
about that and what I want to get out of
this is to understand a bit more of the
technical detail
um you know if you're a robotic is
coming to this it probably doesn't
matter too much about how things are
implemented in the brain if you're a
neurobiologist coming to this you may
not need to know the details of the
implementation as long as you can
understand it conceptually and I hope
the organization particularly putting
things like dependencies into detailed
information at the back
tries to keep most of the text a bit
more accessible the early chapters being
relatively light on the technical
material and building up the concept
Concepts before then moving into the
more um technical aspects
about the uh chapters let's actually
just take a quick look at the chapters
um we're in the uh
Coda document that we use so perhaps you
could just say one or a few sentences on
each chapter what's the short of each
chapter what is it doing in this 10
chapter work
you're testing my memory now the titles
are there the cues are there titles
epistemic cues are there
okay
um well the overview is what it says on
the team it's a description of what's to
come in the subsequent chapters to try
and try and make orientate people
and the low range and high rate I think
again Giovanni has to take credit for
this idea of saying actually there's
quite a it's often difficult to know
where to begin when you're trying to
understand
um active interference in the free
energy principle and the Bayesian brain
and all those sorts of things because it
seems like there are so many potential
starting points
all of which ultimately I think get at
the same thing but knowing where you
begin is is often really quite difficult
um and so these two chapters were
designed to explicitly acknowledge that
um that difficulty
um so the idea of the low road is to say
well let's take a pragmatic perspective
um where we take ideas that have
developed in in Neuroscience based upon
our understanding of of the brain and of
psychology and models that have been
developed to explain those things
and let's take those to their conclusion
which is in a sense the free energy
principle or which is active inference
the idea of
um using our internal models both to
drive behavior and to understand what's
going on in the world around us
um the high road perspective was
designed to take a different approach to
that and instead of starting from what's
already been developed and the sort of
natural trajectory in the neurosciences
um the high road chapter was more saying
let's start from those principles as
much as we can
um and here was a tricky balance to try
and make sure that we we didn't go too
far in depth that we'd put people off by
the by the third chapter but enough that
people might get a bit of a conceptual
sense of where you might go with this
uh and and and here we we sort of
Started from the kind of physics of
sales organization the ideas that come
underneath that and how those ideas can
then feed back into this same idea of um
of accidents that the neurosciences in
Psychology seem to have arrived at
relatively naturally
suppose chapter four is when things
start getting a bit more technical
um and starts dealing with the specifics
that which I think most people would
want to know if they were implementing
these models themselves
um so trying to understand exactly how
you construct an internal model how you
specify how to write it down
mathematically
um how you how you perform inference
with those how you understand the
message passing schemes
chapter 5 then then takes a step back
and thinks well in the context of the
brain in the context of neurobiology
what do those things actually look like
how do we understand those inferential
processes with different kinds of
generative models in terms of what we
know about message passing and synaptic
communication
and and that those those five chapters
together really are the the first
Partners book and the the subsequent
five chapters really then take you
through the idea of actually applying
those ideas in particular domains
um so chapter six is sort of the
overview chapter looking at the rest of
it and it's really setting out if you
wanted to sit down and design a model
either conceptually your competition
these are the steps you would have to go
through to construct that
and then chapters uh seven and eight
take you through that sort of recipe it
for several examples building up
different concepts and both the models
designed in discrete time where you're
formulating things as a sequence of
events
and models formulated in continuous time
we we work with continuous dynamical
systems and differential equations
chapter 9 as I mentioned before you know
one of my interests is in the clinical
domain and trying to understand what
sort of models people
um use to perform inference how those
can go wrong
um and part of part of the research on
that is thinking well how do we then fit
these models and use them to actually
draw inferences about what's going on
particularly individuals or groups of
individuals
um and then chapter 10 takes the
broadest perspective and and looks at
how that relates to a range another
series and and ideas both in the
neurosciences and Beyond
and then I'm sure dependencies speak for
themselves
awesome great overview let's come back
to our questions so
you laid out that the first half of the
book is about learning and the second
half of the book is about applying and
it begins with that recipe
so if chapter 6 is the recipe
as a chef and sous chef yourself what
else have you found was important in the
restaurant what is your full stock
active inference modeling look like and
maybe summarizing in six or going beyond
what was in six like what have you found
to be important as part of the modeling
Journey
especially with teams where people might
have like different levels of domain
specific knowledge or active
knowledge
I like the restaurant analogy actually
and I was thinking I suppose the first
thing that anybody needs to do if
they're setting up a restaurant or a
model is thinking about who their
customers are and what they might want
um and so in the scientific domain
you're thinking well what what sort of
Journal am I planning on submitting to
this to what sort of questions are the
communities who read those um Journal
articles interested in
um and I think that's a really important
First Step so that you know what I'm
actually trying to do with this model
what's not such a good idea often
although you can find interesting things
by doing it is to say well I'm going to
develop a model and work out what it's
for later on you can end up sort of
tying yourself up a little bit by doing
that
although there is value in exploring us
I think we would all agree
and
then
I suppose in terms of in terms of
ingredients It's relatively
straightforward and deliberate
deliberately so I suppose you know the
idea of of these sorts of models is that
they should be relatively accessible
relatively easy to construct with
um without having to make use of large
supercomputers or or anything like that
and a lot of the models that I develop
can be run on a laptop fairly
straightforwardly
um so you know obviously just picking
your your Computing language and how
you're going to construct that there are
now a couple of different options out
there
um Matlab being the one that I think is
most well developed but now lots of
people
um developing python-based
implementations of accidents and schemes
and particularly in the Markov decision
process Realm
um so that gives you I suppose that some
of the key ingredients but then it's
really sitting down and thinking well
how how would I now actually construct
this model and the key question I think
often is
if you have a particular phenomena or a
particular task in mind that you want
model to perform it's thinking well how
would I go about actually constructing
the data that's presented to a
participant performing that task
all presented to an agent and that's
trying to perform this task
and if you can explain how those data
are generated then you effectively have
the generative model that that
implicitly your agent or your
participant or whoever else should be
using to be able to perform that task
so really all you need to be able to do
is to work out how to create the
experimental stimuli and once you've
done that you've almost already created
your model
and the rest comes from
predefined pre-existing inversion
schemes that actually minimize the free
energy for that model
um so at that stage it becomes
relatively straightforward I say
relatively because as anybody who's has
experience encoding knows that a lot of
time is spent debugging and
throwing our barriers and spending a
while trying to work out why with a bit
of Googling to work out a solution
around that
um and I think those are all important
parts of the process
awesome Ollie or Terry on that recipe
and modeling question any thoughts on
that
um yeah uh actually
uh I also wanted to ask if
um uh do you have a plan for uh
extending the uh codes or supplementary
materials to include other languages
such as
imdp packages or
um any other packages that might come up
later and would be widely used in active
inference because as far as I know uh
there isn't any specific GitHub repo or
something dedicated for this book so far
so do you have any plans in developing
such a supplementary material for the
book
we don't at the moment
um it might be an interesting thing I
mean it might be a useful thing to for
to be done by by the actual Insurance
Community as well as a way of sort of
being engaged involved in it
I suppose one of the difficulties of
doing that for a book is that often
these things move on so quickly by the
time it comes out in a book that those
packages have moved on
um so I think you know it was it was
useful for us to give a simple example
of Matlab implementation to demonstrate
the principles in in one of the packages
that we've been involved in developing
as part of the SPM package where we've
been involved in developing the active
routines as part of that
um
and
I think it you know it's it it's
certainly a good idea thinking about
having other
um uh repositories out there with all
sorts of demonstrations so the sbm
package does have a range of different
demonstrations for different sorts of
um uh implementations as well for
different kinds of models which is a
really helpful resource and I I often
suggest to people one of the first ways
of getting a sense of how to build these
models is to look at one that's already
been built and and do their best to
break it
change things and make it behave in
different ways
um and so I think you're absolutely
right to say examples of the code and
how it's implemented are vital in
bringing people into this
um but yes I think you're absolutely
right to say that it'd be really helpful
to have both you know Python and Julia
implementations and and all sorts of
different ways of doing it and examples
so that people can pick those up I agree
completely
and of course one of the advantages of
python and Julia here is is that they're
open source and you don't necessarily
need academic license to use it which
again I think increases the number of
people who can access it
giving an overview to someone who might
not have been following in the blow by
blow of our little literature Corner
over the last few years
how would you say active inference
modeling has evolved during your time in
the space where are we at just generally
speaking with applications what
applications are developed or possible
today that when you were starting your
PhD seemed like they were just
implausible
um
so I think
if we go back a bit I suppose some of
the earlier implementations were almost
all in the continuous domain
um so they're all based upon
um things like the generalized filtering
type algorithms that
um
were initially developed as sort of
filtering out
um methods to perform time series
inference
um those things then
equipped with an active component then
then the canes and the earlier active
inference type simulations and a lot of
that focused on things in the movement
domain whether that be eye movements or
um or control of Limbs to the extent
that you can sort of develop handwriting
and those sorts of things
one of the interesting things that
started to happen based upon that was to
think about how how you then get
something that looks more sequential
emerged from those continuous Dynamics
and handwriting was actually a really
good example of that where there were
some simulations developed in in which
um
in which the continuous model
um effectively had something a bit like
a logical Terror dynamic in it and the
idea bit there being that you can sort
of
um synological Terror Dynamics are a
kind of dynamical system often used for
modeling things like Predator prey
interactions and the idea is that you
get a peak in terms of a predator
population sorry prey population
followed by peak in the pre the
Predators as they eat the prey causing
drop in the prey population but then as
the Predators die out of the prey come
back you get this sort of sequence of
Peaks from Predator prey Predator prey
and you can generalize that to then have
you know multiple different populations
each praying on one another so you get
this sequence of Peaks over time
and that sort of emergence of sequences
from continuous Dynamics I think was one
of the key moves early on in terms of
thinking about things that are a bit
more cognitive in terms of how do I do
this and then this and this and start to
plan and generate much more purposeful
type of behavior
so that that went so far until
um until things moved much more to a an
explicitly discrete or sequential style
of modeling that's when things like
Markov decision presses it started to to
um be employed in the active entrance
domain or partially observed Markov
decision processes so those are models
that say I assume my world is a sequence
of States over time uh one after another
Each of which generates some
observations and from those observations
I can make inferences about the states
you can then say well if I can act upon
the world I can change the sequence of
States
um as they evolve over time
and by selecting different actions I can
or different ways I can change that
sequence and effectively planning and
making decisions so that's again where
you get into a much more cognitive sort
of domain
um some of the key advances
um sort of early on while I was doing my
PhD with the emergence of things like
deep hierarchical
models of things like Markov decision
processes so here the idea was that in
in the world around us there are lots of
things that evolve over different sorts
of time scales
and so
um
one of the the early examples of this
was was reading the idea that when you
move your eyes around the page you're
sort of looking at an individual word or
the letters within that word that that
word is itself part of the sentence and
the time it takes you to infer what the
word is is going to be much shorter than
the time it takes you to work out what's
going on in terms of the sentence the
sentence and the paragraph and the
paragraph on the page and the page in
the book
Etc and so there's a whole hierarchy of
different time scales in the world
around us
and one way of accounting for that
relatively simply in these sorts of
models is to Simply stack them on top of
one another so the outcomes you're now
predicting from a from one of the mark
of decision process type models I was
describing
um now reflects a sequence of very fast
States and each of those States yes
exactly is the the graphic of this and
then each of those
um outcomes predicts another sequence of
very fast States so what you're left
with is at the very top level a very
slow progression of state after state
after state
for each of those states which might be
the sentence you then have the word the
words in that sentence beneath it and
then for each of those words you might
have each of the letters in that
sentence oh sorry in each of the letters
in that word
and
and so that then sort of expanded the
range of things that we can do in terms
of how we
um
give some sort of deep temporal
structure into the kinds of models we
develop
sometimes people refer to that as kind
of breaking the Markov property so for
those who who aren't familiar with this
the Markov property is the idea that
um that
each step in time depends only upon the
step immediately previous to it that
there's no sort of that all you need to
know about the next time step is what's
happening in the current time step
nothing else in the past is is useful
once you know that
um and people often suggest that means
that these processes are effectively
memoryless because it's only where I am
now that matters is not what was
happening well into the past by having a
hierarchical structure where you have a
higher level stage that is more slowly
changing that's contextualizing what's
going on at the lower level it means
that the fast
sequence of changes is actually
dependent upon something much slower
that's happening and that in itself is
dependent upon something much slower and
that gives you this a sort of memory it
allows for the Markov property to be
broken
foreign
so like I said we're sort of starting
off with continuous the emergence of
discrete from continuous the explicit
modeling of continuous models decision
making and the sort of exploration and
exploitation type trade-offs that you
get once you you treat planning as being
an influence process
the idea that you can then stack these
things hierarchically and have a range
of different time scales that break the
Markov process allow us to think about
things like memory and working memory
and I suppose one of the next stages was
the combination or the reintroduction of
the continuous models as the lowest
level of one of these hierarchies the
idea that
actually it's all very well being able
to make decisions but at some stage you
need to implement those decisions in a
world that's made up of physics and
muscle lengths and
um continuous sensory inputs and so
putting these sort of Hybrid models
together where you can use your
decisions to then predict short
sequences and trajectories defined in a
continuous domain
and I suppose since then they've you
know been a range of further
developments in action inference in that
setting
um and a range of developments
in in a number of other directions
um sort of in parallel
so some of those developments have been
thinking about implementation in other
languages some of those developments
have been
thinking about combination with methods
from Deep learning and instructional
variation a lot of encoders and function
approximators and amortized inference
um which a lot of people in the robotics
Community have been pioneering
particularly
um and
so that would be one One Direction that
things have been developed in and and I
suppose the other direction that's seen
a lot of development recently it has
been the sort of underlying principles
the um the physics that underwrites act
again for instance the principles and
how how you justify the sort of Dynamics
and where
where free energy comes from as a as a
concept and why it's useful in
understanding how um systems behave
so that I hope that wasn't too much all
at once but there was a sort of run
through of some of the developments that
um that spring to mind over the last few
years
awesome
Terry or Ali
any comments on that
quick historical review
oh again yeah I had another question
regarding
um actually it's a question
curiosity uh did you have any specific
reason for
um adopting this particular mathematical
notation throughout the book because
um
it seems like it somewhat diverges from
the notations used in some of the
well-known papers uh in the literature
and uh but I know uh active inference
notation uh is not
consistently used across the literature
but even in the papers that came out
after the publication of this book
written by Professor person or others
um I don't see this specific notation
used a lot in those papers so I just
wanted to ask about the reasons behind
this choice
foreign
I think you're absolutely right to say
that it's not always been used
consistently
um and it's worth saying that in some
there are a couple of different tensions
that that affect this so one is the idea
that in a lot of papers that are
published
um because it's only dealing with an
aspect of active influence and not
trying to to try to put it all together
they can sort of use a notation that may
be the same as notation you might use in
another field
um without worry that people will will
get conflicted and misinterpret one
variable for another because
everything's just defined within that
one domain
and another aspect to it is that in
depending upon the paper in question and
the audience is aimed at sometimes the
notation is designed to
um to match what what might be used in
that broader field
um whereas we've tried to try to make it
as consistent as possible across
different fields
um
were there any particular notations that
you were thinking help clarify
uh yeah so for example
um as just a very simple example
um
using
ETA for external States instead of X
that's been used or S and a for
um active States and sensory States or
other kinds of uses of lowercase
matrices and uppercase matrices which is
used differently in a paper such as a
step-by-step tutorial on active
inference and these kinds of notational
divergences
okay um so yes I mean there's some quite
nice illustrations so things like a and
S which as you say are often used in
some of the more physics orientated
papers
um
unfortunately if you use those in a
mock-off decision process paper people
will interpret those as being States and
parameters of a likelihood Matrix
so unfortunately we couldn't use those
same letters without causing more
confusion
so what we try to do there is to to
focus more on the um sort of practical
inference side of things of you know the
actual implementations we tend to use of
active elements in particular problem
settings and there when you're
constructing a generative model
um particularly if it's in the
continuous domain we'll often use x as
being the states that I have to infer
which from the perspective of the
physics type papers are the external
States the things that are having an
effect on my sensory States
um we we've
I can't remember whether we used y or or
or o for the sensory States or the data
in the book and it's why as you think is
why okay
um and that that sort of fits with the
idea of using it as in the continuous
domain where in
um in a lot of settings when you're
trying to predict
um sensory data often why will end up
being the variable at the end of Newton
um so I I appreciate that it can be
confusing sort of jumping between
different resources
um but what we stroke for in this one
was internal consistency as much as we
could and trying not to overload
specific variables
or symbols
thank you
thanks
bigger 4.3 we bound ourselves coming
back to again and again it four sages
chapters seven and eight
and it lays out discrete time on top and
continuous time on the bottom in terms
of their structural similarities but
also they have some really important
differences so could you just as you see
it how
do the discrete time and the continuous
time models
have similarities and differences such
that you can lay them out in a
graphically or visually similar way yet
there's also some key differences for
example in what each of the nodes means
so how are they similar and different
and what did you hope to illustrate by
laying out figure 4.3 this way
so I suppose the reason that they can be
seen as similar is that effectively what
you're trying to do in both cases is to
represent a trajectory we're trying to
represent how something evolves in time
and that's something maybe the state's s
in the discrete time or they may be the
trajectory of some in States X in the
continuous domain
and when you're trying to say how do I
actually
put together a set of numbers that tell
me how something's evolved or evolving
there are a couple of different ways you
can do that one is to say I'm going to
tell you where it is at time one and
then I'm going to tell you where it is
at time two and then at time three etc
etc
and that's a perfectly legitimate and
perfectly reasonable way of writing down
a trajectory
it obviously misses out all the times
between time one and time two which may
or may not be significant depending upon
what the problem is you're dealing with
uh
the second way that we approached is to
say well you can you can use what what's
known as a Taylor series approximation
or a Taylor series or a polynomial
expression or that trajectory
um so essentially what we're saying
there is that you you just construct
a function that is that that follows
that the the the shape of that
trajectory over time and you can
construct that function by saying well
let's look at where I am now at this
point in time and my position
how am I changing at the time if you
just took those two variables together
you just have a straight line telling
you where you are and where you're going
to be
if you then take account of your
acceleration you may even now have a
curved line which says if I'm here now
I'm going to be there then
um and as you add in more and more
elements to this so the rate of change
of the velocity and the rate of change
of the rate of change of the Velocity
Etc and just add in more and more rates
of change you effectively get a more and
more precise function telling you at
least locally around where you are now
where you're going to be at various
other times
um so that that difference the either
using Taylor series coefficients which
are just
um successive rates of change
or by using a sequence of States over
time are what's Illustrated in in the
lower and upper
um Graphics here respectively
um each of those things has there as you
said that they have a lot of in common
in terms of their sculpture in terms of
the num or the number of numbers you
need to be able to describe them
um but it has their advantages and
disadvantages depending upon what you're
trying to actually model
and I think for me I tend to think of
the the sequence of categorical States
over time as being quite useful in
thinking about anything to do with
decision making deciding between
Alternatives
um thinking about sequences like
language and words and or even sequences
in terms of the eye movements you make
looking in one place then the next and
the next rather than continuously moving
your eyes around space in a smooth
fashion
uh whereas the process of interpreting
sensory data that's coming in from your
retina or from your your stretch
receptors or whatever else or in terms
of actually driving action that changes
continuous variables in the world there
I think is much more useful to be able
to describe things in terms of a
continuous number and those sorts of
continuous trajectories that you can get
through using these Taylor series type
approximations
which often referred to in this context
as generalized coordinates of motion
awesome
cool well another figure that we come
back to again and again tucked away in
chapter nine but giving a lot of context
is uh figure 9.1
on what is termed meta Bayesian
inference so could you describe what is
happening in this figure
and is this exactly as every empirical
ethologist is going to agree with is
this controversial is this novel so what
is it doing for octave inference when we
conceptualize our
empirical task
structurally like this and do you think
that that is exactly how ethologists
have long seen this topic or is this
something contentious
I think so I'll I'll talk through the
figure but then but then you can tell me
if that's how ethologists traditionally
look at it and whether whether it's
contentious I'll be interested to
um
so the the idea behind this figure is to
to highlight that when when dealing in
psychology or Neuroscience or Fields
where you're trying to understand
um
our particular system is behaving or how
it's
um
essentially what's going on in the mind
or the brain or the nervous system of of
some creature that is behaving in some
way
um there are two levels of which you can
look at it one is saying well from my
perspective as the experimenter
what are the data I'm measuring and that
may be behavioral measurements from that
creature it may be taking
electrophysiological measurements it may
be
asking it a question if it's a patient
in a clinical setting
um and
I'm essentially now trying to optimize
my model of this system
now
in the neurosciences and in the settings
I've outlined above the the
um the kind of system we're interested
in is the sort of system that has its
own model
of other sorts of system
and so the kinds of questions we're
interested in the kind of parameters
we're interested in are things like the
prior belief that this creature has
about this thing
or how precise it thinks it's data are
and so the parameters I'm now asking a
question about are the parameters of the
beliefs of another of another system
so the outside box here
um the the one that the parameters are
going into the experimental stimuli are
going into and The observed Behavior
coming out of
um is essentially my model of how this
other system behaves
now the inside box there the one in the
dotted line or the dashed line
um that now represents the model that
that system has
to understand the world around it
um and so when when we construct our
model that contains another model inside
it
um and by saying if this creature
believed this this is how they would
make inferences about their environment
and generate Behavior I can now predict
the behavior I would observe if this
creature
believed this thing
um so the subjective objective idea is
that the objective model is is the
experimenter
um and its beliefs and the experimenters
beliefs and the observations they make
by measuring what the participants or
experimental subject does
and the subjective model is the
participants model of the world around
them
so that I think would be my summary of
how this figure works and the the idea
it's trying to get across now you can
tell me how ethologists
May disagree with that or agree with it
or what they'd find controversial
I'll give a thought and Ali or Terry
feel free to give a follow-up or a
thought
I don't think in principle it's
contentious or dissentious
however there might be an explicit or an
implicit belief
course ironically that we can simply
take
some of these parameters coming into our
experimental setup
and even the selection of experimental
stimuli we can take those as simply
given which is a very frequentist
perspective and then on the observed
Behavior we can simply use descriptive
statistics
we'll characterize the predefined groups
according to the one experiment we ran
we'll do the t-test we'll do the Anova
we'll come up with a p-value it's going
to be frequentism all the way forward so
even if we're doing frequentism about a
generative model
there's a sense that if we just clamp
down on our experiment and treat it as
handed down without error instead of
being actually drawn from distributions
of possible experiments we could have
done
if we clamp down Upstream of the
experiments we'll just be able to
describe and ultimately publish without
needing to look at what else could have
happened
and I think this diagram and also the
very subtle dashed line around even the
bigger box
suggests that just like the active
clinician engaging with a conversation
or the active experimenter also engaging
iteratively over their system of
Interest
that itself
is an Adaptive epistemic process
where
yes you could simplify it by treating
the parameters and the stimuli sequences
as simply given but then you don't have
access to the generative model that
actually is the generative process for
the subjective model
so summarize in principle uncontentious
however sometimes discordant with the
ways that behavioral experiments are
conceptualized planned and analyzed
one reason why it's helpful because
during the book we we try to stay on the
road on the high road of the low road
but
um
when we're in discussions
it's almost like there's a whole road
map and people have their own
backgrounds and questions and it kind of
comes together with all these different
um
topics that people are curious about
ultimately that bring them to active
inference so
going to this metabasian figure
helps in some ways situate
how the authors are seeing this entire
process
of
experimental design observation and
cognitive modeling and that was unpacked
also in the recent map territory fallacy
fallacy work
Ali or Terry
any
thoughts or questions in our last 10
minutes
is there a figure you want to look at
or we can go to some other places
maybe we can ask the missing figure in
uh it was in I think it was in figure
seven point
yes yes or something 7.2 in the lower
left
so then this was actually corrected by I
I don't know quite how it ended up
Vanishing but it was corrected in one of
the later print versions I'll see if
it's in the version of course in front
of me now and I can show you what it
would have looked like
um but apologies for that uh which
figure is it
7.2 on page 128. and
um unfortunately I picked up a copy of
the book that doesn't have it
um so there have only been one and a
half fractal dimensions of printing
yes
um yeah I think unfortunately I don't
think that one's corrected yet in the
online copy
um essentially what would have appeared
in that that figure or what did in some
of the later printing versions is
um
the errors that are driving the updates
of the states in the plot above
um now because the
so the errors here are um are
effectively the
um are the free energy gradients so uh
or the negative three energy gradients
so essentially the
um
as you as you go down the free energy
gradient you're effectively minimizing
your error
so what that means in practices that the
errors would effectively be the rates of
change of the states and the plot above
so if you take the states and the plot
above and you imagine what the rates of
change of each of those lines are that's
what you would get in the plot below
well on this same kind of Topic in
chapter seven we're in the discrete time
generative models and um
a little bit less so here but in the
latter models
here
in 7.13
and in what we just looked at in 7.2
where are these continuous
interpolations coming from
if it's a discrete time model
that's a good point so I I suppose
there's an important distinction between
if there's there's the distinction
between
um the things that are being inferred
which are happening over discrete steps
in time and then there's the inference
process itself
um which deals in probabilities which
are themselves continuous they can vary
in this case anywhere between zero and
one
um and the time over which that
inference happens
so
to give you an example if you imagine
that you're you the way you're analyzing
this figure at the moment is by making a
series of category movements and you're
not you're not sort of continuously
moving your eyes from one block to the
next you're making a series of rapid
um ballistic movements that
um and take you from one to the next
um and effectively every time your eyes
stand still you have a new data point
that you're now trying to analyze
you can imagine that that between that
or every time your eyes stays still
everything else in your brain doesn't
just stop
um so once you've got that new data
point your brain now has some time to
simulate that data point to draw
inferences about what is seeing there
and those inferences happen through the
continuous dynamics of what's happening
in in your neurons and various networks
across your brain
um so you can think of the continuous
changes that are happening for each
state as as not being changes in the
world that we're trying to infer not
being changes in the data point I'm
currently looking at the changes in my
beliefs about it before I then sample
the next data point
um
interesting
I have a few more figure based quick
questions but Terry do you want to bring
up anything or just give any remarks no
worries if not
well I I
am very much just trying to understand
these Concepts so I I don't make any
pretense uh having any deep
understanding but the the key thing that
interests me is how you jump from this
sense of uh how we update our
predictions
into the clinical realm and I I I'm
interested in pain medicine and I see
neuroplastic pain is very much a
um
mistaken prediction based on often uh
misinterpretation
by medical professionals and the
information that they give to patients
and I'm really intrigued by the
potential for uh
using these Concepts to to give patients
an architecture in which they can start
to understand that they can that they
have some agency and altering their
future predictions and really change in
their experience of their pain and and
as you're a clinician I'd be really
intrigued to
get your sense of where this is going in
that type of print clinical Realm
um
I think that's a really nice example as
well thinking about
um thinking about
attitudes was pain and particular kinds
of pain particularly when there isn't a
sort of obvious tissue damage that can
be identified that's um that's causing
that pain that still is obviously a very
real sensation to the people who are are
experiencing it
um and I think it generalizes to a
number of other other conditions
um and probably there's an overlap with
things like functional neurological
disorders probably a number of medically
unexplained symptoms and things where
that there is a huge amount of overlap
in these sorts of processes where you
can't necessarily directly identify a
big structural lesion of any sort but
clearly the way the nervous system is
working
um something isn't quite isn't quite
right
um pain I think is an interesting
example particularly because
pain is never a real thing out there in
the world is it I mean it's it's always
an inference and so I think that's one
of the first things to say to anybody
you know regardless of whether he got
pain because you've lost a leg or
um whatever else it there's no such
thing as pain as an external state it is
just your inference your explanation for
the the
um signals that are coming in from your
body
um
now one of the important Concepts that I
think comes into all of these
um sorts of syndromes and probably many
others as well is the idea of precision
the idea that
um the data I predict sensory data
coming in
um I I can in addition to estimating
what those data are going to look like I
also have to estimate how confident I am
in what they're going to look like
um if I'm not very confident or I think
I'm dealing in something that's very
noisy then I can actually discount a lot
of that
whereas if I believe that it's all
extremely reliable very clean data
that's coming in then I want to put a
lot of weight on that
and another way of saying that is that
there are some things I pay attention to
and some things I don't
um
and
you know just saying it's reliable data
is just a matter of saying I'm going to
attempt to it
now it might be that in a number of
these different syndromes
um what's going on is that our bodies
have
um overestimated the Precision
overestimated how clean the data are
coming in from a particular body part
um and that that's why we then over
interpret any signals that are coming in
as if they are painful and the
influences we draw from those signals
are just too confident and too driven by
something that they shouldn't be
an example I often like to use in in
clinical discussions is that it I told
you to imagine to pay attention now to
the the feeling that your left sock is
having on your left big toe you can
probably feel it
um but you were completely unaware of it
before but now if I say continue to pay
attention to that and carry on paying
attention to that and and you're unable
to pay attention away from it anymore if
you felt that all the time it would feel
unusual it would feel wrong
um and
um maybe a misestimation of precision in
that way maybe what's going on in a lot
of these sorts of conditions
partly I think it's often interesting
that in in some of these people there's
um there was at some stage an injury or
something that affected that body part
and you can imagine that if you went
through a period of illness where when
you did have tissue damage and we're in
pain for that reason it might direct
your attention to that and you may have
a learned deployment of attention
towards that area
that might persist even after
um even after the the insults and the
damage was resolved
um and again maybe maybe it's that sort
of persistent uh mislearning of
um how precise things are that leads to
the continued experience of pain even
when there's nothing
um sort of externally causing it anymore
so I think just having a sense of
inference and of um
and the idea that that Allah
perceptions of the world around us are
ultimately inferences
um says that you know if we change our
model in some way we're able to adapt
and change and develop plasticity in our
our brains and spinal cords can be
exploited uh then then we can also um
correct those mislearned models
um and hopefully resolve those sorts of
symptoms and syndromes
awesome
thank you well we are at the very close
really appreciative Thomas of how much
we were able to cover
what are your closing words or thoughts
potentially to someone who has listened
to this one hour discussion as their
appetizer before joining the par at all
restaurant service
um
well I know I've I've enjoyed the
discussion thank you for having me here
um
I that it sounds I mean I'll reiterate
what I said earlier that I think one of
the key things in in making this field
more accessible to more people are these
sort of
um uh reading groups the ideas of trying
to create these educational resources
and to unpack and discuss these things
um and you know I'm impressed by all the
infrastructure you've put together and
um and by everything you've managed to
achieve by doing this
um so I'd certainly encourage anyone
who's interested to join up to your
reading groups
um and I hope they they get something
out of it and out of the book
thanks Ali
well uh yes um actually since the
beginning of the first cohort
um this book has practically become a
part of our life that we love and
cherish and uh it's amazing to see how
with each iteration of our reading group
uh it gives rise to whole different set
of questions and and discussions and uh
actually I'm a firm believer in this
famous quote I don't know by whom which
says that the sign of a great book is
not how many answers it provides but
rather how many thought-provoking
questions it engenders so based on that
Criterion and judging by the variety of
questions uh brought up during our live
discussions as a kind of empirical
evidence for that I think it's probably
safe to say that this is truly a great
book so congratulations on that and
thank you
thank you very much
great closing thoughts so Thomas thank
you again you're welcome back anytime
thanks Ali and Terry for all the great
participation and until next time
bye